I think humans are built to serve I
think if you're not happy it's because
you're not serving every day we all want
to wake up and feel like what we do
matters to somebody else we want to feel
like the job we're going to or the
business we're creating or whatever
we're going to do today is going to have
an impact on somebody else everybody
wants to serve serving others is
hardwired into our brain did it
functional MRIs on people's brains and
found that serving other people hits the
same part of your brain as having food
and having sex so it's like literally
hardwired into your brain that you need
this to be a functioning happy member of
society I encourage entrepreneurs to go
through a three-step process which is
eliminate automate delegate so you look
at the work that you're doing and maybe
you shouldn't be doing it at all like
before you give it to somebody else
maybe it just shouldn't get done and
there's there's often things that we're
doing that we think are really high
value that then turn out to like to not
matter need motivation watch your top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I don't
always wake up and feel motivated to go
take on the day and the thing that saves
me that helps me every day is being
around people who are thinking bigger
who are changing the world and it gives
me a little more inspiration to go after
my mission and so I hope this video
helps you go up to yours today too so
today let's learn from me and my team's
take on my top 10 rules of success enjoy
momentum is something I've been talking
about for years I often say the biggest
thing people are missing is just
momentum when I'm helping entrepreneurs
and I'm I'm looking at people and yeah
Scott I know you've met a lot of people
like this too who've got like a great
idea a huge heart a desire to serve like
a passion to do good not not just make
money but to actually try to create
something meaningful
it's like but why haven't you started
it's like the biggest thing you're
missing is just momentum is what I would
always say is a as a catchphrase I guess
to just like let's go just stop being
afraid and just go and create and so I
actually wasn't planning on writing
another book my last book was built to
serve and if you had asked me at the
beginning of last year what's your book
it's built to serve when's the next book
it's not like it's built to serve that's
it and then I did an Instagram live with
um Kira
who became a friend who then became uh I
became a business partner with her in
her publishing house and she said she
was a book medium
when I met her at genius Network and I
said well what's a book medium it's like
well I help people Channel their books
it's like okay I like their Vibe and her
energy I had no intention of writing the
book but I said hey why don't why don't
we do it as an Instagram live
like what do you mean come on my
Instagram and you can Channel my next
book with me do your thing with me right
it's like oh no it's usually private I
don't do this as a public thing okay but
just come on come on we'll do it
together it'll be fine so she was
nervous but she said yes and we
channeled my book and out of that came
the idea of momentum
and
then she said okay well when are you
gonna write the book
well it's called momentum so it's kind
of hard to delay that right it's kind of
hard to say well and next year I'll
start right it's like so I guess I'm
starting today and they ended up writing
the book this book so it's a it's like
not a giant book but it's not a little
book either in five days so I wrote the
whole thing in five days uh we then got
it
You Know cover printed all of the stuff
that has to go into publishing a book
inside of eight weeks it started with
her challenging me to write the book in
eight weeks and in context my first book
with penguin Random House took me a year
to write
so even the idea of writing the book in
eight weeks was already massive uh time
crunch because I didn't have eight
magical weeks just open in my calendar
like I've got my software company
running I've got my YouTube Team running
we've got 50 people on the team you know
like there's a lot of work that has to
get done now magically have to write a
book as well
and I just started writing it was
flowing out and I actually got it done
in five days and said why don't we just
get it published in eight weeks instead
of me having it written in eight weeks
and um yeah so there it is momentum rule
number two is focus on your mission how
do you get to that level because there's
so much noise isn't there there's so
many people competing and people get
this is a bit of a long-winded question
but people get very disheartened because
they don't get immediate results so they
say oh it doesn't work so what would you
say to those people
well I don't know if you've seen my
journey I post it on my website so if
anybody wants to see how how uh slowly I
took at the beginning to get going uh
people use it as inspiration
um I post every year so I started uh in
2009 and every may I post where where
I'm at in terms of my subscriber growth
and in the first year was 25 subscribers
in the second year it's like a 100
subscribers something in my fifth year I
still had 700 subscribers or something
like that and that's like people will
say how did you not quit like how do you
keep going how are you in year five and
you only have 700 something subscribers
like you might want to go find something
else
I mean I was like it's not working go do
something else uh
so I I mean I just I love doing it and I
think that's why you have to love the
process of the thing that you're doing
yeah if anybody people you know I
challenge people to do this because it's
a fun thing but a lot of times people
will take take that graphic of how I'm
doing year by year and then they they
put it into an Instagram post or video
or tweet or something to say that
they're beating Evan Carmichael because
most people are beating me most people
by year five you know already have more
than 700 something subscribers so you
can say that you're ahead of me the only
difference is I kept going
I know I just I just kept going I kept
making it I kept creating content I kept
sharing and when people ask well how did
you keep going like how did you not quit
I what gave you the inspiration and
reason to keep going I always focus on
who I was serving instead of who I
wasn't
okay that made a huge shift for me
because we all most of us are in the who
I'm not serving game right even now I've
got three whatever million subscribers
why is it not four why is it not five
why is it not ten you know what the the
who I'm not game is never ending but who
you are serving right now
can make all the difference in the world
so that those 25 people in my first year
it's like those are 25 people who
subscribe to my channel you know like
that's pretty cool I thought that was
pretty cool if you go and you speak at a
at a library or a YMCA or my first
speaking gig was at a YMCA and 25 people
show up that's pretty cool now I thought
I would think that's pretty cool my
first speaking I had three people show
up so if 25 people showed up that'd be
pretty cool and so if you can if you
could re-engineer your mind to to think
about that that hey if I have 25 people
or 100 people or a thousand people or
however big your audience is it doesn't
mean that you stop growing and you get
complacent and you just only live in
gratitude for what you've got but if you
focus on serving them instead of who
you're not serving it does a couple
things one it's a lot more fun
yeah I feel like you matter and that the
work you're doing is having an impact on
people and that fun we all want to feel
like we're doing something that matters
since you can actually connect the thing
that you're you're doing actually
matters to somebody maybe not the world
you and I want to serve the world cool
and if you knew that you did something
today that helped at least one person
it's easy to have the motivation to keep
going it and do it again the next day
the next day the next day and two the
people who you are serving will take you
the people who you're not serving you
know like if you keep serving your
people well they'll tell them they'll
tell their friends about you say hey go
watch this person's video
um and you never know the impact that
you're having on people well number
three is believe what advice would you
give to folks who are listening to this
who know that they're destined for more
and what message would you like to leave
them with today just to know that it's
possible
that whatever that dream in your head is
that it's actually probably even small
compared to what you're capable of
and that is possible and that people
with
less intelligence and less resources
than you Your Heroes a lot of them
started with less than what you have
right now you have Stephen to pay
attention to you know a lot of your
Heroes didn't have anybody and they
figured it out and so they can you can
too and it requires a different way of
thinking it requires a different way of
acting it requires you maybe saying no
to some people and then saying yes to
new people and new opportunities in your
life but your dream is possible
and you just have to wake up every day
and take one more step towards making
momentum happen towards it because I
think for a lot of people the biggest
thing they're missing is just momentum
rule number four is overcome your fears
walk us through an average every day for
you as a high performer
well average every day or or when I was
on tour doing that tour on tour on tour
yeah so part of the reason for doing the
tour was
I was afraid of speaking and I'd done a
lot of speaking but it was always this
like
uh you you speak and then it you're
scared and then I come back home and
then I'm fine and then you I was I
wanted to get rid of this fear of
speaking and so I thought okay I'm just
gonna go and do 23 cities and every four
days speak again every three four days
like a new new city do it again do it
again do it again do it and get my reps
in and that became the starting point so
every fourth day basically I was in a
new city speaking uh every fourth day we
also had to travel we still had to work
uh and I wanted to spend some time with
Nina it was me Nina and my cameraman
Danny for 90 days together
Hotel hopping Airbnb hopping it was it
was a pretty chaotic but fun ride also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is invest in
yourself in what way did you get better
and what did you invest in so it was it
was mindset and skill set so in the
mindset I I'm introverted I'm shy that
doesn't come across on like interviews
like this but
I don't like the spotlight I don't like
being in I don't like being on stage
um it makes me nervous I it's not it's
not enjoyable just came back from a
three-day event in Vegas where I was
speaking with with garyvee and Patrick
David and other great speakers on stage
and
I don't like being on stage I like the
effect it creates in the hallway
afterwards to go help people so I'll I'm
the only speaker who sticks around and I
stay for hours in the hallway talking to
people
um because they'll come up to me and ask
me questions based off of my talk where
normally I would I wouldn't go up to
anybody and talk to them not because I'm
I'm too good for them but because I'm
afraid you know I'm introverted and shy
but we still want to serve and so that
was that was a huge breakthrough for me
when I realized even though I'm
introverted and shy I still want to
serve I still want to help and all my
models at the time if you look at who's
on TV you just see the people who are
big mouth and extroverted in the life of
the party and like that wasn't me so I
thought oh like to do that you know I'm
at the same agency as Mel Robbins and
Grant Cardone and both of them very out
outwards focused and like the life of
the party and extrovert and love talking
to people
um and just that wasn't me so I I it
took a while for me once I titled the
service then it wasn't online because
like it's not about me it's about the
people you can help and then that became
like oh okay but how does an introvert
make a lot of YouTube videos and when
I don't know but we'll just figure it
out you know like let's try let's see
what happens
um and then the second part of that was
was getting help in communication and
getting once I decided to take it more
seriously that I realized oh I should be
doing more than than um yeah just
getting coaching getting help and watch
my videos back and becoming a better
speaker so
people can get there a lot faster it's
not like oh once you have a thousand
subscribers or a hundred thousand
subscribers or a million subscribers or
whatever it is then instantly everything
gets better it's much more about are you
are you good enough or you have the
skill set and the talent and the mindset
to actually make great content and
obviously the more repetition you put in
the better but but getting coaching and
getting help and getting people to give
you guidance
um really helped me too rule number six
is model success on your mission
that you're on what challenges with that
format that you've built uh have you
faced for what's next and what's been
the advantage of that format for what
you've been able to build and the impact
that you're making in the world it's my
biggest limitation is still lack of
belief
yeah so
people say well you're the believe guy
it's like yeah but I believe in myself
to do the things that I've done now but
to do the next the next big thing I
don't believe myself do to the next big
so I still need the channel for myself
because I want to wake up and have Oprah
Winfrey or Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or
whoever it is we're spraying messages in
my ear to get me going to do the next
thing
um one of my my uh you talk about the
format of of giving tribute to other
people at the beginning it was just hey
I've learned this from these people and
I think you might be able to learn too I
was just hoping to shortcut the path
because my my worst day in my first
business was when I said I quit on my
business partner
and I woke up the next day and said I
can't quit yet because I'm going to
regret this if I don't figure this out
at least at least if it doesn't work out
fine but at least know that I gave it
everything because I don't want to look
back and say I wish I just tried a
little bit harder
but I couldn't keep going the way that I
was going so I had to find another path
and the thing that came to me was I
can't be the first person to try to
solve this problem like somebody's
figured this out why don't I just model
success like that wasn't model success
it wasn't words that I would use you
know it was probably a lot more clumsy
but I can't be the first person to
figure this out somebody's done it and
that's where I studied Bill Gates it's
like Bill Gates had a like who's got a
software company I had a software
company so who's got a successful
software company Bill Gates came to mind
like this was not very Advanced planning
it's just top of Dome uh so okay how did
Microsoft get started and how did he
build like not so much how did how does
Bill Gates make an extra million dollars
now who cares but like zero to one how
do you do that and it was through
Partnerships and in learning how he
applied at Microsoft I brought that to
my business and quickly after I had my
first check for thirteen and a half
thousand dollars and that may not seem
like a lot but when you're making 300
bucks a month like 13 and a half K it's
like holy cow this is a grand slam here
and more importantly I could do that
again that was just one deal I could
close more deals so the idea the
strategy there was model success find
people who have done this and put that
the use in your business or your life
and so I I then went on this mission to
continue learning how I can model other
people's success and then like that
eventually became my YouTube channel
where I shared a lot of messages
um a surprising benefit of that has been
I've gotten to meet some of these people
you know like I was just profiling some
of them and then now I get to do
interviews with them or go hang out with
them or go to their houses and some of
them have become friends which was never
part of the idea of what I could do it's
just hey I love your message
I'm trying to get it out to the world
because if I learn from it maybe other
people like me can learn from it and
it's been amazing to be able to Foster
all those connections too rule number
seven is eliminate automate and delegate
I encourage entrepreneurs to go through
um a three-step process which is
eliminate automate delegate okay so you
look at the work that you're doing
and
maybe you shouldn't be doing it at all
like before you give it to somebody else
maybe it just shouldn't get done
and there's there's often things that
we're doing that we think are really
high value that then turn out to like to
not matter
and we may not even notice it right I
mean before movement makers I had a
mastermind that I ran in Toronto for
entrepreneurs and when people joined
um we took uh minutes like notes of what
was happening like I took minutes is
before AI could do it for you and
transcripts like I wrote down minutes
for what everybody said and homework and
assignments and everything and um there
was one month where
I forget what happened like I was going
away the next day or something and I
didn't get the notes out to people after
the meeting
nobody cared
like no response no message no like Hey
where's the minutes where's the notes
and I and so I didn't do it again next
month nobody cared it's like wow I've
been spending all this time on something
that like nobody cared about that I
thought was high value but was actually
zero value for people
um maybe it was even negative value
maybe I was annoying them with it I
don't know uh and so eliminate first you
know so I mean a lot of entrepreneurs
might be frustrated with their
accounting and bookkeeping uh you cannot
eliminate that right like that has to
get done yeah he will run into problems
if you try to eliminate that from your
business right and I was going to go
into that for you but yeah keep going
yeah the government will come for you
that is a big problem uh unless you live
in some country that that doesn't move
to the moon or something but
um yeah you know that's a problem so you
can't eliminate that but but there's a
lot of things that we're doing that just
should not be done to just be completely
eliminated the next is automate so
before giving it to a human give it to
technology so use software use tools use
AI use QuickBooks use like there's a lot
of things there's software and tools for
a lot of things that you should should
start applying into your business
uh that can save a lot of man hours
um and then you get to delegate so
eliminate automate and then delegate and
so these are the things that still have
to get done
but should not be done by you so in
eliminate they shouldn't be done at all
and automate they need to be done but
should be done by a human
and then in delegate it's it's it should
be done but shouldn't be done by you has
to be done by another human
and that's where you start to scale and
build and create rule number eight is do
what makes you happy if you're trying to
get your journey going on YouTube cool
take a bite and see try making videos
try doing Vlogs try doing interviews try
doing direct to camera try doing
speeches try the things that you see and
expect to suck at all of them at the
beginning you're not going to be good
because you don't have the skill set yet
it doesn't mean you suck as a human you
just you don't have the skill set yet
but the thing to pay attention to is did
you enjoy it how did you feel after
doing it you had that interview and it's
easy to go back if you go back and watch
your first interview it's a train wreck
I mean you're awkward and nervous and
ask the wrong questions and you can look
back on it and say oh my gosh I should
have done that and you can go over it in
your head a million times but like but
did you like it you know like was it fun
to do do you want to go back and do it
again did it give you more energy than
it took and if it's a yes then that's a
great sign to keep going
and so a lot of people stop on YouTube
because they don't get immediate results
because they're not doing something that
they feel is authentic to them
um and they're focused on who they're
not served instead of who they are
serving
um and they just judge themselves too
harshly for not having a skill set yet
like you don't just get on a snowboard
and go down the hill
you fall 80 times on your first run and
then you fall 50 times on your second
run right you just you get better as you
go rule number nine is make the
difference you think that for people who
are looking at making an impact whether
that be online or through content or
speaking or any of those different
Avenues where do you see that kind of
the next Horizon kind of like you enter
YouTube very early on what do you
think's next
so I think it depends on what your
mission is right so for me I've got a
giant mission right I want to impact the
whole world and so how do you do that
well
my hypothesis is that it's content at
scale
and if you're going to do content at
scale you've got two options long form
or short form like the platforms are
basically divided Tick Tock and snap and
Facebook and Instagram are all short
form content and then YouTube is long
form and YouTube has shorts I guess is a
combination but there's YouTube on one
side with the long form and all the
other content which is short form and if
if you want to have an impact and really
want to make a difference I I think it's
hard to do it in 30 second little Clips
so that's a lot more inspiring but it's
not really making a huge impact if
you're trying to explain multi-family
investing
in a 42 second video like good luck
right so so but it's fine like the
shorts have their own path it's to
inspire but it's not really to to do
deep education and you're not really
doing any of the deep work just from the
clip so hopefully the clips Inspire
somebody to
start down the path to learn more about
this thing and remember 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
be in service to others talk to me a
little bit about the service mentality
and that service above self mentality
that I mentioned because I feel like
it's really
um a part of your core it's something
that you really really authenticate
so I haven't heard of uh service above
self before but I'm also not part of
rotary and um I think ultimately service
is the path to self
I think I think humans are built to
serve I think if you're not happy it's
because you're not serving
every day we all want to wake up and
feel like what we do matters to somebody
else
we want to feel like the job we're going
to or the business we're creating or
whatever we're going to do today is
going to have an impact on somebody else
and some people you and I and probably
most of your listeners we want to change
the world we want to have a big impact
we want to go and you know have our
message reach wide and far but not
because of us but because of the impact
that we want to create
and other people like my wife Nina
she doesn't want to have a big mission
but she serves the 25 closest people to
us she's the glue for our family
remember everybody's birthdays and what
they're doing and what they need and
what they're going through and all of
the stuff that I forget and probably I
should get better at but everybody wants
to serve
serving others is hardwired into our
brain they did functional MRIs on
people's brains and found that
serving other people
hits the same part of your brain as
having food and having sex
so it's like literally hardwired into
your brain that you need this to be a
functioning happy member of society I
think some people
have experienced things like active
kindness you know how nice it is to buy
the coffee with the person behind you in
line or hold the door or those kinds of
things and those moments are great and
keep doing them but I think everybody
also has a much deeper level of service
where I believe that your purpose comes
from your pain that whatever you
struggled the most with as a human is
what you want to help other people
through and so
when you can see somebody who is going
through the thing that you went through
and feels hopeless and lost and is
struggling and doesn't see a way out and
then they spend eight minutes with you
you say hey you know what it's okay it's
like I went through that too and here's
how to get out and then you see hope
in their eyes for the first time and
like you made that happen you caused
that and then that's that little that's
a that's a spark in their life that can
change the entire trajectory of their
life that's the thing they get addicted
to like that's what we all want and I
think we're living in a world now where
a lot of people find zero meaning in
their work they're driving to a job that
they hate and I'm just trying to ignite
some passion in people
I am not feeling so hot this morning
don't know if it's just the lingering
effects of the uh variant or what but
um just super low energy a little
nauseous a little dizzy but uh still
getting my still getting my son stuck at
my walk still gonna do my fast and still
make as much progress as we can some
days you can do more than others just
make sure on the days that are less than
others
are you still getting something done but
you don't mail it in if you don't give
up then you don't quit what's the quote
sometimes you can fly sometimes you can
take the car sometimes you can run
sometimes you can crawl
keep moving forward keep moving forward
when life gets hard when you have every
reason in the world
the turn back what do you do you press
forward discipline is your missing
ingredient you've got the heart you've
got the care you've got the desire to
serve you know you could be doing more
you want to do it for the right reasons
you're not just here to make money
you're here to have an impact in the
grow and do amazing things you know you
can do amazing things what's missing
discipline
there's just a lack of follow-through
it's the constant start and stop and
start and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me the
only one of the only reason why I'm here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post my socials
of how I grew month over month year over
year on YouTube and in the first five
years I had 7 000 subscribers or so
five years in five years in of making
content
7 000 subscribers
a lot of you already ahead of that a lot
of you could get there a lot faster than
me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had the discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
and 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be as slow as me you know
I took I took a long time and I had a
lot of issues I was shy and secure and
introverted and felt like you had to be
you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limiting
beliefs all sorts of issues and you can
get there a lot faster than me but it
still requires a discipline to follow
through and do it and I really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me I use the Fitbit watch and it tracks
my sleep and it gives me a score every
day for how well I slept and I've hit I
think 89 out of 100 as my best sleep
score and what I would love to do is to
improve my sleep score one of the best
things that happened to wearables you
have something that you can track so I
want to find a way to consistently be in
the 90s and have an excellent amazing
world-class sleep so on the on the first
day that I was tracking that I did not
use earplugs I got an 88 sleep score
which is pretty good already up there
uh when I moved to the I don't have any
more thrown away but I had the kind of
black just ones I think I showed earlier
in this video uh very standard just kind
of running the mill black earphone they
didn't do anything I got an 80 sleep
score but they were barely in it wasn't
really pulling anything
um any of the the audio out then I went
to the hardcore ones and these ones are
amazing these are the ones that I wore
at the Tony Robbins event that I was
right up against the speaker and it
really pulled it out so if you want a
good earplug whether for sleeping or not
the brand is called Heroes Heroes but
with an A so like Heroes there's only
one left in this pack extreme protection
earplugs 14 pairs nrr 33 I think that
means something uh these are amazing
knocking out the sound so on the first
day I got an 84. so nothing no ear plugs
was 88 black ear plugs kind of standard
ear plugs got an 80. these earplugs went
up to 84 so I'm going the right
direction on the first site on the
second night though it actually fell
down to 73.
uh what happened was I had this in and
when I was sleeping it caught on the
side and it jammed further into my ear
and it hurt and it woke me up so it
didn't have as good as sleep and so I
decided you know I'm not gonna wear it
I'm not gonna wear it the next day and
and I haven't I haven't gone back to it
so overall I don't think earplugs are
the solution for me so I'm not gonna I'm
going to be using these
I think the main reason is I don't mind
ambient noises you know if something uh
something broke or something fell or
there's a loud noise a crash bang I'm
gonna wake up but overall I kind of like
the ambient noises it's kind of like you
know a a sleeping machine with the white
noise or I used to fall asleep listen to
sports radio at night I like having a
little bit of noise going on so the
earplugs are not helping me improve my
Sleep Quality I don't think they're
hurting except when it germs into my ear
and it causes a lot of pain so I don't
think it's hurting but I don't think
it's helping me the environment makes
such a huge difference for who you are
and your daily habits and what you
believe about yourself and the
environment is not just the people who
are around you although that definitely
helps you know if you've got negative
friends or family around you you want to
eliminate them completely or spend a lot
less time with them because it's really
really really hard to have a beautiful
plant grow when it's just you know toxic
waste being poured on top of them doable
but really really difficult and so
changing that can really help and one of
the best ways I found to do it is
content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully
you wake up today and there's a piece of
content there waiting for you whether
it's me or showcasing somebody else
across all my channels or making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem and just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that is happening in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence I think comparison to
other people is fantastic I think most
people just do it wrong I think most
people just do it wrong you look at
somebody else you see their life you see
what they're doing you see their
business see the success you see how old
they are is one of the common questions
people ask well how old are you well
typically it's because they want to they
want to judge their own progress against
yours
the comparison can be great but you have
to use it as a kick forward instead of a
kick down most people will kick
themselves down they realize that you
haven't you realize you haven't done
much you realize that you're not where
you want to be you realize all these
other people have done it with maybe
less resources than you at an earlier
age than you and you feel like it's over
and you can't do it that's a kick down
it's a comparison it's a kick down and
that's what most people do and that's
why there's so much advice out there
from people saying don't compare
yourself to others because when we do it
we typically kick ourselves down that's
the wrong way to do it the comparison to
other people
comes from knowing what's possible and
being inspired to want to go off and do
it
you know I just came back from a trip
with my beach gang and it's
some big name people it's Brandon
burchard and Mel Robbins and uh Lewis
Howes and Jay Shetty and you know all
these all these big people who've done
big things
and we sit around the table
and we share and we help and it's our
own Mastermind it's not a paid thing
it's where they go and and we all share
and as they're talking this they're
sharing what they're up to what they're
working towards
I'm thinking that's what's possible
that's what I could do if I wanted to
that's what that's how they're doing
their marketing okay if I could do this
and maybe they're three years ahead of
me but by learning their strategies I
can get there in six months
the comparison pushes you forward
runners run faster when there's somebody
next to them businesses innovate faster
when there's competition
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday is not enough of a push
forward that's the problem comparing
yourself to who you were yesterday is is
a great it's great for self-love
but it's not enough of a push
so I'd encourage you to start thinking
about an audit for yourself right now
if you're really low
if there's no self-love
if you don't feel like anything is
possible that's where you look back and
you look at the progress that's when you
look back and say where was I five years
ago where was I 10 years ago look at how
much you've grown and learned and
improved and how much in a better
situation you are compared to where you
used to be even if it's not financially
just mindset just mentally just the kind
of person you are how you treat people
you've probably grown if you're watching
this channel
it means you're into personal growth
self-development
so whether it's from my videos or
somebody else's content you've been
learning and growing over the past five
years you've grown a lot you're not the
same person you used to be you're a lot
more proud of yourself than who you used
to be and whenever you're feeling low on
yourself that's when you look back and
track the progress that's when you look
back and see who you used to be and how
much you've grown and improved and
gotten better and that can
start to fill you up again
but when you're ready for growth
when you're ready for ambition when
you're ready for the next level
I think the comparison is fantastic
I think to know that something is
possible it's the whole Roger Bannister
four minute mile nobody thought it was
possible then Roger Bannister did it and
now everybody's doing it not everybody
but a lot of people did it why because
they were comparing themselves to him
because they know now that it's possible
and so when you see somebody else do it
when you see somebody else making
amazing things you don't have to default
to say I suck because they're doing it
and I'm not that's a kick down you can
choose
to use it as inspiration to say that's
what's possible
and if she can do it if he can do it
then so can I
and use that as the push to get you to
the next level
at our beach gang
last year
I got challenged a couple times I got
challenged by Brendan I got challenged
by Russell Brunson I got challenged by a
whole bunch of people and and I got
challenged without people even talking
to me sometimes just by them sharing
their story
I look at that and say I want to do that
not in the way that I suck and I can't
do it but no in a year I want to be
there in two years I want to be there in
five years I want to be there I want to
be there I want to be there I look at
young Les Brown I think he's the
greatest speaker of all time I don't
look at him and say
he's so much better than me he's got
this natural gift I suck I'm never going
to do it I look at him and I say I want
to be that good that's what's possible
it's an inspiration to move forward
so how do you make it tactical
there's a couple things that I think
would be helpful for you
one
look at some people who you respect
inside your industry or outside you're
interested it's just something that you
respect about them maybe it's me maybe
it's Jordan Peterson maybe it's Oprah
who are the people that you look up to
and respect what are the things so too
what are the things about them then that
you want to get better at if you respect
somebody's because they're they're ahead
of you
it's something that you want to be good
at
maybe it's in their business maybe it's
in their speaking maybe it's in their
relationships they've done something or
they're living a way that is ahead of
you
so what is that thing too what is that
thing what is the thing that they have
that you are aspiring to get better at
there's no one person who is the ideal
Mentor you don't want to be me you don't
want to be Jordan Peterson you don't
want to be Oprah
they have parts of their eye Parts in my
life that you don't want
the whole point is to take different
pieces from different people to make the
best you you want to for me I wanna be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs that's why
he's on my wall and I want to be a
father like my father was that's why
he's on my wall I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs was and I don't
want to be a Visionary like my dad
because they're not
so you're taking different people and
different things from them to help you
become the best you
so one is you're making a list of all
the people that you look up to that you
respect that there's something about
them that you you gravitate towards to
you find that specific thing I wanna I
Wanna Have Courage like this person I
want to have love like this person I
want to be a husband or or a wife like
this person right I want to be a mother
or father like this person that they're
the ideal to shoot towards and improve
you to make you want to strive to get
better
and then three you dive into their story
you dive into their content you dive
into their videos their books their
podcasts their biographies you dive into
them on a consistent basis watching One
video is not enough it's a consistent
basis to help you start
to think like that
somebody asked me yesterday why do you
read so many books at a time I read
seven to ten books at a time I never
really thought about why I do it it just
seemed to work for me but as I dissect
it I love micro dosing on books I love
micro dosing on content because think
about what happens when you read a book
so one of the books I'm reading right
now is Jay shetty's think like a monk so
when you're reading Jay shetty's book it
it forces you to start thinking like a
monk it forces you to have more presence
and more gratitude more mindfulness and
if you're going to read some hardcore
the other another book I'm reading is 75
hard from Andy frizzella which is in
your face hardcore punching you in the
stomach you know yelling at you let's go
two totally different Vibes I like both
I don't want a bj Shetty I don't want to
be any frisella
but I like the mindfulness and present
of of Jay Shetty and I like the
aggressiveness and push of Andy for sale
in in that combination is Evan
Carmichael
so why I read seven to ten books at a
time is because the micro dosing of the
books when you're reading a book if I
only read Jay shetty's book I've become
very mindful very very grateful very
present and then I put the book down and
I pick up a different book and then what
you start to do is lose
the train of thought you lose the thing
that you learn from Jay unless you're
picking up another Jay Shetty book but
he's only got one out right now
so instead instead of going hardcore and
just reading one book I like having Jay
Shetty once a week I like having any
fisella once a week I like in the videos
that I make to have different people we
have Jordan Peterson once a month and
Elon Musk once a month and Oprah once a
month because diving deep on one person
can be great
but what happens on the ongoing I'm much
more concerned about the ongoing than I
am about the what's happening intense at
the moment
because the ongoing is how you win
if you want to have success in anything
going going to the gym and working out
for four hours is not going to do much
for you but if you go to the gym every
day for half an hour you start to see
results
a bunch of stores in there but the main
concept is I think comparison is
fantastic you just have to use it
smartly when you look at somebody else
understand that you don't want their
entire life
you don't want their entire life
but there's something about them that
they're better than you at and use that
as inspiration for you to get better
instead of you telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it
comparison will push you forward
comparison will help you get the life
that you want as long as you're kicking
yourself forward not down if you want a
guaranteed way to move into action apply
the 595 rule spend five percent of your
time planning and 95 percent of your
time doing five percent planning 95
percent doing most people are afraid to
apply the 595 rule because you're afraid
that you'll take the wrong action that
you'll make a mistake that it won't be
perfect but here's what's going to
happen while you are sitting there
planning your perfect next move someone
with less Talent with less skills than
you will win with a half-baked idea
because they applied the 595 Rule and
just got started and then don't think
about it
and do it
stop planning that's the plan the plan
is done stop planning now do the reason
why you're not following through is
because you're doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else
it's just
massively difficult to follow through
still possible absolutely but this is
the life of an entrepreneur this is why
so many great entrepreneurs don't follow
through and it
breaks my heart because
You've Got Talent you've got a desire to
serve and the help and you know you have
a story that matters and you're just not
as consistent as you know you could be
and it's not that you suck it's just
that you're doing it alone this is
something I've struggled with
in terms of being a great resource for
people because I actually have a very
low Community need I think the journey
that I went through is
almost impossible to model
because I just woke up every day and I
still made videos and I still make
content and I did it by myself and it's
not prescriptive it's really difficult
to
do it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it but I have a really low
maybe it's just introverted or or uh
whatever but I just don't need it as
much as most people
you probably need more Community you
probably are not following through
because you feel isolated and alone and
the great promise of Entrepreneurship is
freedom right like you don't have to
have a boss you don't get to you don't
have to have employees that you hate or
people on your team who you hate you
know you get to pick everything you want
but then to go from having a job where
you have Community even if it even if
you didn't enjoy the work you were doing
which you got from the job if you've had
one is community that you had co-workers
and you had some people who you did like
and you had people to go to lunch with
and you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that
nearly as much or at all
and so it's very lonely
and it's really hard to do great work
when when you're lonely
so what's the solution
no you're okay great yeah you just tore
my heart open Evan now what do I do how
do I fix it well first it's just
recognizing that that is a problem you
know first it's recognizing that there's
nothing wrong with you there's nothing
wrong with you you're amazing the only
problem is you just don't have anybody
that you're collaborating with that
you're doing this by yourself so the
answer is we need to now go and find
other people to collaborate with is to
get really clear on what the Habit is
that you want to develop don't pick 20
different habits that you would want to
do all at once this is where we we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it I'm done I'm rolling
up my sleeves it's time to change my
life I've had it I've had enough I'm
gonna change everything I'm gonna work
out and I'm gonna I'm gonna eat well and
I'm gonna make content I'm gonna grow my
business I'm gonna find a girlfriend I'm
gonna like whatever the thing is you
come with 20 different habits that
you're gonna do
and guess what you do it tomorrow maybe
and then and then it becomes too
overwhelming too much too much change
all at once
your life just takes over and you end up
back down in the hole where you started
does that happen if you tried to take on
too much at once what is the single most
important habit that you need to start
to build that if you look back in a year
you could say I'm so happy that I built
this one habit because it's helping you
accomplish your goals what is the most
important habit it could be waking up at
a certain time it could be taking care
of your your mind it could be taking
care of your body it could be putting in
a certain amount of work on your
business it could be right in your book
it could be making 100 videos like what
is the one habit
that you want to start to build that if
that one thing happened
your entire life starts to change
it's the Cornerstone habit that you
start doing that because they guarantee
you listen if you start waking up at a
certain time or you start working out
you pick any of them you start doing one
of those things that you're proud of
yourself for doing it other things start
to change in your life around you
because when you feel really proud of
yourself when you feel good about
yourself
other things start to improve too that
negative voice inside your head that's
telling you that you suck and you can't
do it that's not your voice
that's not actually your voice that's
not you telling yourself that you suck
that voice was planted there that voice
was put there by somebody else in your
life and probably early on growing up
telling you that you can't do something
you were not born you didn't come out of
the womb and say I suck I can't do
anything no you're playing you're
experimenting you're finding Joy you're
laughing you're you're doing it
and then along the way people tell you
that you can't do it that you should
stop that you should quit that it's not
gonna work out that you can't do it and
we've been so conditioned around that
that we take it on and we think it's our
voice
when you come up with an idea right
just Workshop this you come up with an
idea and say oh I'm gonna I'm gonna go
I'm gonna write a book I'm gonna start a
YouTube channel I'm gonna launch his
business I'm going to whatever you can
put your your bucket list your your
dream life your vision boards you come
with a list of ideas things that you
think that you want to do things that
you
feel confident that you'd love to create
for yourself right okay what happens the
next day the next day
it's not even telling our friends you
know I think we we blame our friends and
say well we tell our friends and they're
going to be negative and and they they
crap on our idea and so we don't do it
well before that happens we crap on our
own ideas
right you look at that list the next day
and say I can't do that who who was I
yesterday this crazy person that I used
to be yesterday who thought I could do
that
it's ourselves telling ourselves that we
suck but the problem is we've taken on
that voice and we think that it's us
that's not your voice that is not your
voice telling you that you suck that is
somebody else's voice that was planted
in your head that has been conditioned
to be there that we're so used to being
there that we have taken on as our voice
it has become your identity but it was
not your voice it was put there it was a
seed that was planted that has been
grown over time and you need to rip that
weed out
that is not your voice
you do not think that you suck
it's other people with low expectations
who hate their own lives who at some
point went and tried something that did
not work out for their life and now
nobody around them can have success
because it makes them look and feel bad
and so they spend their time ripping
other people down and apart
that's who planted that weed in your
head that might hit pretty hard I hope
it does because when that happened when
if you can actually
digest that
what ends up happening is you think oh
who whose voice is that who's whose
voice is in my head and that's great
awareness to know that it's not your
voice and then to identify whose voice
it is who told you these things who made
you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh or that was my
you know the bully at school whoever
that person was now think about okay
it's that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly liberating
but then two do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life
if you don't want their life then you
definitely don't want their voice in
your head anymore
hopefully that creates an aha moment for
you that starts to actually shift things
because we've been so conditioned to
listen to that voice that we don't
recognize that we actually have a choice
to rip it out
and start to listen to our own voice
so that's step one step two then is
whatever you want more of in your life
you need to be surrounded by it more you
need to change the environment your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you where you are
and if you're watching this video I love
you thank you for being here you are
probably the happiest most optimistic
most positive most caring most pouring
into other people that's in your
environment if you think about you and
your friends and your family you're
you're the most optimistic person in
your family you're the most positive
person in your family you're the most
ambitious person in your family you're
the one who wants to care and serve the
most in your family right but
you know you're capable of way way more
right you know you can do way more than
what you're doing right now
and so you end up being this big fish in
a really tiny pond where you're serving
others and porn and others and you wish
they could do more and that's amazing
don't stop caring for others but you
need more of a push yourself you need to
be around the people who are doing
things that you want to do on a higher
level
so the environment really matters in
your environment right now is is good
it's it's not terrible maybe it is
terrible but it's not great
most likely it's just good
and it keeps you stuck and it keeps you
in slow growth mode and it prevents you
from becoming the person that you
actually want to be
so how do you start to shift that will
you shift your environment
and you may say well Evan I don't know
people who are super accomplished and
are living the life that I want to live
I don't have any of those friends if I
did I wouldn't be still stuck here and I
hear you I get it so the fastest way to
do it isn't through actually trying to
make those friends it's
through what I call aspirational mentors
it's by watching videos like this you
may never meet me you may never meet Mel
Robbins you may never meet whoever your
heroes are but you can learn from it
through these videos whoever you want
more of whoever you you respect and
maybe you're even jealous of that they
can think that way and live that way be
around them more
look at who you subscribe to on YouTube
look at who you subscribe to and follow
on Instagram look at the books you read
in the podcast you listen to and the
shows that you watch are they from the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and give you hope inspiration
and courage to go Live Your Dream and if
not then switch it out
switch it out
if you are watching YouTube when you
just found that you you wasted the last
three hours of your life
it's not YouTube's fault
it's your fault
you're subscribed and watching the wrong
videos
because there's a lot of positivity out
there if you close a YouTube session you
feel worse about yourself then you
subscribe to the wrong channels if
you're watching this video and feel
worse about yourself one I sincerely
apologize and two you should unfollow me
and go follow somebody that that makes
you feel more hopeful and Alive because
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel hopeful alive bold
confident powerful things are possible
your life will change
but we need that external stimulus you
are a product of your environment you
have to have those people around you you
can have Elon Musk and Mel Robbins and
Tony Robbins and whoever pushing you
every day you can have them pushing you
every day
by consuming their content we just
happen to be enslaved
by
the things that are around us that we
haven't designed with intention that's
all yeah YouTube the algorithm is so
addictive
so addictive you you get one video that
then takes you down another path and
another path and all of a sudden you've
just watched three hours of videos on
something that doesn't make your life
better you don't actually really care
about you just got sucked into the drama
of a certain storyline has that ever
happened to you
remember I watched the Michael Jordan
tribute the last dance and I went to
research
one of the story lines of Scottie Pippen
and Michael Jordan to see kind of what
the 2022 updated version was and all of
a sudden I got down this Rabbit Hole of
Scottie Pippen versus Michael Jordan and
three hours later there's still other
videos to watch like what am I doing
this is a waste of time I don't even
care that much about these guys
I watched the last dance it was a great
documentary and and I learned from it
and I love the drive and tenacity and
hustle but I don't care about the drama
between Michael Jordan and Scottie
Pippen and so we will easily default
back into that Comfort mode and back
into consuming drama
you have to with intention try to bring
that back
so here's a grid
homework assignment go look at your
YouTube homepage and see what's being
recommended to you and how many of those
videos whether it's my Channel or other
channels how many of those how many
videos on your home page right now will
make you a better human will make you
feel more proud of yourself will make
you feeling hopeful confident courageous
ready to take some action on some of
your goals and how many of them are
drama how many of them are pure
entertainment how many of them you know
will lead to some giant rabbit hole that
you don't want to go down if you
actually set out your calendar and say
how do I want to spend my day with
intention how many of these videos would
actually lead you towards that path
right and for too many people it's it's
not a it's not a pretty picture
we're listening to the wrong people and
so you can change that
you know you could change that if we
Circle back you recognize that the
negative voice in your head is not your
voice it was planted there by somebody
else who hates their life and you don't
want their life
then you switch it to say okay well
whose life do I want and ultimately you
want your best version of your life but
to get there you're taking different
pieces from different people's lives
like oh I like how he does that and she
does that and and she does this and
you're pulling different people
different things from different people
and then you start to surround yourself
with that
and the shift doesn't happen overnight
but if you're constantly pouring these
people into you if you're constantly
pouring having Carmichael into you
you're gonna start to believe more on
yourself
and if you're constantly pouring other
people into you you're gonna start
thinking like them behaving like them
taking on their mindsets and their
beliefs
and if those are beliefs that you want
and the mindset that you want amazing
you get to choose now
you're in control
you've been a product of your
environment your early environment with
negativity your ongoing environment with
probably just mediocrity keeping you
where you are and now you can change it
you can shift it you can decide to be in
a different spot one year from today
and the most important step you can do
is to start choosing and carefully
decide with intention who you want to be
around
so that in one year from now you are in
a different spot not just for you but so
you can serve others and lift them up to
catch up as well
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome pretend
more amazing reels from Tom bill you
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there what do you need
to do on this day to achieve your goal
do you do it or not it really is that
cut and dry and if you're looking over
your shoulder for somebody to save you I
can tell you right now they are not
coming no one is coming to help you